Cuál es la efectividad real de esta
medida genera un impacto importante para
la economía rusa o es más bien un gesto
simbólico
no hay que recordar que
la reacción inicial de la Unión Europea
cuando
inició la Guerra era tratar de prohibir
completamente las exportaciones rusas de
petróleo y gas ya que pues representa la
forma en que ese gobierno se está
financiando está financiando la propia
Guerra y después de todos estos meses
llega a este acuerdo de poner un precio
límite a las compras es decir se puede
comprar el digamos yo yo la señal la
interpretó así se puede comprar petróleo
ruso siempre que se respete el precio
límite de 60 de 60 dólares
No qué fortaleza tiene el gobierno ruso
digamos para poder sentirse preocupados
sobre la posibilidad de que este precio
máximo opere Yo te diría mucho lo va a
definir la propia naturaleza Es decir el
nivel de frío con el que se presente el
invierno europeo
bueno Y de alguna manera la Unión
Europea justamente podría verse más
afectada que Rusia con el tope
sin duda de ahí que haga yo mención al
invierno el invierno va a definir si la
Unión Europea tiene suficientes o no
inventarios para enfrentar en las
temperaturas y no tener cortes
eléctricos o cortes de energía si se
vienen una situación vamos a decir de
este tipo de este riesgo pues muy
probablemente esta decisión firme de no
comprar la energía rusa y
a menos que fuera por debajo de los 60
dólares se vea seriamente cuestionada
Entonces sí hay una hay un balanceo
vamos a decirlo así natural de fuerzas
en estas dos posiciones que dependen
mucho como ya lo mencioné de la
naturaleza bueno y Moscú ha asegurado
que está dispuesta a reducir su
producción cuál sería el impacto para
los mercados energético Claro claro esto
esta posición de hecho la empezamos a
ver con con las expectativas de anuncio
de incremento en la producción de la
OPEP sin embargo no ocurre así la OPEP
decide mantener su nivel de producción
actual lo cual desde mi punto de vista
es una señal clara de vamos a ver cómo
se comportan los mercados y vamos a ver
si efectivamente
conviene o no conviene al bloque subir
la producción de tal forma que la
incertidumbre es muy alta e insisto hoy
es muy difícil poder decir que la medida
va a ser exitosa que realmente va a
afectar las finanzas rusas
toda vez que ya lo dije por tercera vez
Perdón vamos a depender fundamentalmente
de el frío que haga este invierte bueno
y brevemente le pregunto Rusia Confía en
que su petróleo se puede redireccionar
hacia principalmente china e India esto
realmente puede funcionar Bueno sí china
e India han estado comprando volúmenes
tan importantes de petróleo ruso que
realmente la producción
rusa de este hidrocarburo ya muy
parecida digamos a los niveles que se
alcanzaron en 2019 es decir en los
hechos en realidad no hemos podido ver
como planeta una disminución de la
dependencia que tenemos de la producción
rusa de hidrocarburos